大家好，我是Sam，PlanetScale的CEO。我们是一家云数据库公司，为全球一些最成功的科技产品托管着一些最大的数据库。我们有三项主要服务。
Vites，就是分片MySQL；Niki，分片Postgres；还有PlanetScale Postgres，这是全球最快的Postgres托管服务，运行在我们自己的金属服务器上。基础设施一直是我整个职业生涯的痴迷所在，我热爱支持那些改变世界、为杰出人才创造价值的产品。
比如，Cursor就是PlanetScale的客户，我非常自豪他们能在PlanetScale上运行非常庞大的分片数据库。他们在改变世界，能参与其中真的非常了不起。
我的演讲主题是：智能体如何改变了基础设施的角色，以及这种变化将如何持续演进，基础设施又该如何向智能体提供简明扼要的指令和洞察，让它们能够安全地操作基础设施，不造成任何损害，在真实环境中完成工作。
而且，即便发生了意外，任何差错都可以被撤销。所以，我的演示会使用智能体。这是一个特别的会议，庆祝一个特别的产品，我想让这次演讲与众不同，所以几乎全程与智能体协同完成。
你们看到的每张幻灯片也都是用Cursor开发的。重要的是要记住，智能体是非确定性的，每次我演练这个演示，它都会做出不同的举动，但最终总能达成目标。
而且，我们是在一个设计得极为安全的系统上构建。PlanetScale是高可用服务，所以它可能会直接阻止我们的操作，让智能体停下来，至少我们会看到这样的情况。
我们听过很多关于数据库和智能体交互的可怕故事，现在我们将看到另一面。我们现在就开始，先启动一个演示，因为这需要一些时间，然后我会带你参观这个产品。
刚才你扫了二维码，会看到SFM Mart，这是我为创业者开的店。网站很慢，但我们卖的都是好东西，适合搬到旧金山创业的人。不过，性能真的开始拖后腿了，订单量也受影响了。
你看，这里我们设置了Grafana，这个站点托管在Cloudflare上。可以看到订单率还行，我们做得还行，但查询速度真的很慢，平均查询时间……”
店是给创始人开的，确实慢，但我们卖的货很棒，专门给来旧金山创业的人。但现在性能真的开始影响订单量了。
我的网站能接收的订单有限。你可以看到，我们设置了Grafana，这是一个托管在Cloudflare上的实时站点。订单率看着还行，我们还在正常运营，但查询耗时确实很高，平均查询时间远超正常水平。
差不多要四秒，最慢能到五秒，这可不妙。我们知道，要是产品太慢，用户就会放弃结账。这个数据库就托管在PlanetScale上，只是一个简单的三节点集群。
然后我们有个小工具，可以实时看到智能体在忙什么。我们现在想让数据库提速，所以打开Cursor，开始第一个演示。我就是让智能体去检查一下PlanetScale有没有什么优化建议，然后照着执行，顺便优化一下代码库，看看效果如何。
我现在就启动它，它马上会开始规划行动。就像我说的，我们待会儿能看到性能上的变化和差异。
我们现在看智能体的视角，一旦它们跑起来，就能看到它们怎么一路狂奔、开始干活，瞧瞧它们在搞什么名堂。
我们想展示现代基础设施平台的安全特性和各种机制。我们还故意塞了一些指令，让智能体可能犯错，希望它们跑起来的时候咱们能看到这些情况。
看，它已经开始列出模式更改，准备派生出子智能体了。它们随时会冒出来，而网站还是特别慢，一切照旧。我们还有负载和订单在继续生成。
我们等等看，它正在验证状态，看吧，这是非确定性的，只能耐心等它们准备好开始干活。现在它已经开始编辑、运行，读取PlanetScale API了。
主智能体马上会把任务分发给几个子智能体。所有东西都跑在Composer 2.5上，我们这儿构建的几乎都是，运行飞快，才能实现这种并行处理。好了，子智能体们开工了。
谢天谢地，子智能体们跑起来了。看，它们正在干活呢。这些可爱的小机器人正在经历各个阶段，探索PlanetScale为它们准备的各种信息。PlanetScale会生成洞察报告。
你可以看到，它会推荐各种数据库改动。这个原本是为人设计的，但现在对智能体也特别好用，我们会带入大量上下文，尽量解释清楚发生了什么，指出需要编辑哪些查询。
我们还会建议改表结构。我们有自己的模型，会实际测试索引建议，看看性能提升效果，然后生成推荐。我们会建议删掉一些索引，或者提醒你整数空间快用完了，这些以前都得靠数据库工程师手工处理。
这些都是实实在在需要处理的数据库问题，现在全都自动化了，我们有了这些自主的“工程师”——也就是智能体，它们能搞定这些活儿。
我们看到它们正在执行任务，跑得飞快，我们也跟着推进。接下来咱们去看看这些智能体具体做了些什么。
所以就像我说的，这些操作已经用来部署我们之前提到的、添加索引的架构变更了。我们能精确看到改了什么。这就是所谓的部署请求。那么Planet
Scale允许你给数据库创建分支。分支的目的是给你一个类似生产的环境来做修改。你可以在这些分支上做架构变更。当你准备好部署时，就创建一个所谓的部署请求。嗯，
它正在推进，正在执行，而且已经部署了。你能精确看到架构里改了什么。在我们的洞察图表里，甚至会有一条漂亮的标记线，显示那个时刻发生了什么变化。现在这真的
很有用，因为在这个现代世界里，智能体会不断让你的基础设施变得更好。你想确切知道发生了什么，对吧？必须得知道，你知道，最糟糕的莫过于凌晨
两点被叫醒，生产环境挂了。你完全不知道怎么回事。我们把所有变更，包括异常、错误和问题，都关联到你看到的每一个图表上。然后我们精确展示出查询语句以及它们
运行的频率。所以你能看出这肯定是订单查询。对，它快多了。我们在Graphana里已经能看到。我们大幅降低了那个查询的性能开销。我们还通过嗯spark
线条标记了出来。呃抱歉，就是那些标记线，让我们能看到，我们的网站运行得快多了。看看我们的智能体视图在干什么。哦不错。这是一个坏家伙智能体，它卡住了，这些都在扮演我的角色，
但我们拒绝了删除某一列，因为那会破坏正在进行的查询。所以PlanetScale做的是：它查看你所有正在发生的查询。它检查部署请求是否会破坏那些
在数据库里活跃的查询，然后就不允许你这么做，除非你显然要强行通过。嗯，但我们成功阻止了一个智能体搞垮生产环境。太棒了。这对确定性来说是好消息。太好了。我们
添加了缺失的索引。谢谢。谢谢。嗯，呃，所以是的，我们还在继续推进。我们看到部署请求在发生。分支在被创建和合并，我们的网站越来越快。我们在Graphana上看到了。我们的订单量稍微更
稳定了一些。嗯，我们每秒的查询数上升了。这是个非常棒的变化。我真的很高兴。好，看看这里还有什么别的在发生。那么，我们这里还有另一个智能体在工作。你能看到这些
都是真实的，对吧？它们一直在做它们的工作。这些都是嗯真实发生的事情，在朝着目标前进。我们重写了一组查询。嗯，我们删除了冗余索引。我们添加了遗漏的索引。而这一个我们要
盯着看。现在，这个智能体正在做一个我们想要让它失败的变更。我们去Cursor看看它进行得怎么样。嗯，它正在跑一个冒烟测试。好。那我们给它几秒钟做这个。所以这个智能体实际上会被允许
把非常糟糕的东西推到生产环境。嗯，你会看到那已经发生了。我们失去了对某一列的访问。那非常糟糕。嗯，我们的网站再也加载不了了。PlanetScale特别的地方之一，就是我们
能把这些东西回滚。所以，我们刚删了一列，生产环境里有了一个新版本的表，但从那以后我们一直在以中间状态写数据。所以把这个列恢复回来，通常可能相当困难，对吧？
在99%的数据库里，你现在就得在生产环境做恢复了。数据还在往主库写。如果还有什么能工作的话，你得拿到一个版本和一个快照来嗯恢复服务。
有了PlanetScale，我们其实不那样做。我们保留一个长时间运行的窗口，让我们能把架构翻回刚刚那个版本，而不丢失任何数据。所以，我要点那个。而且它非常非常快。它花
的时间是一样的，不管架构变更有多大。所以客户经常在100TB甚至更大的表上做架构变更。我想我们见过六七百TB的表用这个流程被修改，而它
仍然会以完全相同的方式回滚，我们刚刚非常非常快地撤销了一次本可能持续数小时的严重故障。安全地让智能体去做它们的工作。所以这就是智能体视图。它们都完成了。坏
家伙被阻止了，我们拯救了局面。我们现在有一个更快的网站。好，谢谢。你能在这里看到快速查询对页面加载的重要性，对吧？你的产品越受欢迎，它就越慢。你看到这个瀑布流了吧，
对吧？要完成一次页面加载，如果查询越来越慢越来越慢，我们真的会嗯削弱产品的体验，没人想要那样。现在我们的查询更快了。嗯，我们成功了，但网站的需求也增加了。更多
需求，数据库负载更大。从根本上说，我们需要处理更多查询。所以我们要给数据库分片。这就是我们当前的问题，对吧？我们有三台数据库服务器。一个主库和两个副本，用来
保存我们的订单表和我们整个数据库的一份副本，嗯，支撑我们的应用。这两个副本的任务就是保存主库中数据的那一份副本。副本也可以用来嗯
在主库丢失时故障切换，以实现高可用性，并且真的有一份副本，这样即使失去主库也不会丢数据，但我们需要更多容量。我们已经到了纵向扩展的极限，需要给数据库分片。
分片，对于那些不知道的人，是一件非常难实现的事情。它基本上让你把一个数据集拆分到许多数据库集群上。每一个都是一个完全封装的数据库集群
每个分片都有自己的主节点和副本节点，分布在不同可用区。主节点和副本节点都不在同一可用区，这样分片带来的弹性就大大增强了。比如我们可能丢失主节点，
也可能丢失副本节点，但最多只是丢掉一部分数据，整个数据库对外仍然是一个整体。应用仍然以为自己在连接一个单一的数据库，访问一份连续的数据集，但实际上我们已经在运行一个
分布式系统，复杂度和特性都大大增加了。接下来我们马上要开始分片演示，我会在数据库层面讲解分片过程中的操作。你们可以
实时看到状态更新。我们会展示分片执行过程。第一步是排队等待，准备就绪后部署变更。我们会运行所有PlanetScale的预检查
确保一切正常，然后进入数据复制阶段。光是分片和数据迁移我就能讲两个小时。我们把一个数据库集群中的整套数据，
分布到16个分片上，并在迁移过程中保持同步。我们还会进行复制。因为新数据会不断进来，我们不能简单恢复备份就完事，否则备份之后的数据就全丢了。
我们需要复制，持续不断地复制。然后还要验证，对两个数据库中的每一行做校验和，确保数据完全一致，这样才能保证
不丢失任何数据。接下来我们要切换副本节点。在应用中切换读请求风险较小，PlanetScale会自动处理副本的切换。如果应用
直接访问副本节点，PlanetScale会将读请求导向分片集群的对应副本，应用无需任何改动。然后我们对主节点做同样的操作。这是一个更大的变更，不是
单向操作，实际上我们还可以回退到单一集群。我们反转复制方向，这同样很难操作。现在我们有16条独立的复制流，把它们合并起来再复制回未分片的数据库。
然后分片就完成了。数据分布在16个分片上，一切正常。分片过程中还有一个最困难的部分。我见过有些公司的分片项目
耗时三到四年。这需要大量的代码重构。我会解释为什么，并深入探讨Cursor在这个演示中扮演的角色。首先，我就说一句：现在让我们给这个数据库分片。非常简单。
就这样。实际上非常困难。我早年曾在GitHub工作，当时我写过一个issue，说要尽量避免分片，因为直到现在分片都是
极其困难的。现在我们在看分片需要做什么准备。接下来我们要讨论应用层面的事情。也许我需要刷新一下，看看底部会不会显示出来。
哦，可能不会加载了。看看它会不会马上推送数据。是的，好了，工作流在运行了。谢天谢地。现在你能看到它在排队处理不确定性问题。好的。
第一个要素，这不只是PlanetScale的演示，我们是在用PlanetScale平台展示这些基础能力。我相信未来每个基础设施平台都需要构建这些基础能力。
这只是一个实际应用，而且数据库是极其严肃的。如果我们能在数据库上做到，那其他任何地方都可以。第一件事是vSchema，PlanetScale通过它
知道如何告诉Vitess分片策略、分片位置和数据定位方式。这很酷，因为它是声明式的，允许智能体来构建这个vSchema。这是一个示例vSchema，智能体
会根据PlanetScale技能库中的知识构建出这个或非常类似的东西。我们告诉它这是一个分片数据库，应用一个vindex，也就是哈希，这样数据能均匀分布，
并且每次查询都能找到相同的数据。然后我们定义vindexes，决定按什么键分片。这时候你真的需要团队协作或了解产品，并有能力
重构代码来理解这一点。大多数公司都有一个天然的分片键，比如Shopify按商店分片。实际上有很多选择，但选对分片键
非常重要，我稍后会解释原因。你可以看到我们已经开始复制了，很好。Vitess正在按我们的要求工作。我还可以展示，目前应用完全不受影响，它已经开始
这个工作流，但应用运行得很好。我们决定按items和orders表分片，这是我们最大的表，而且我们还需要引用products表。这就是
重构变得至关重要的地方，这也是为什么Cursor承担了很多工作。我们现在需要改变应用执行join的方式，因为我们会在orders表上join products表。Vitess
会为我们做一点魔术：它会把products表物化到每个分片上。这样一旦到了分片，我们就能在products表上做join。如果你现在在旧版本中执行这个查询，
在旧集群上，你只需要一个简单的 select 查询，就能拿到你想要的数据。但如果是在分片集群里做这件事，就会触发所谓的 scatter gather 查询。你可以看到，它会扇出到每个分片，再汇总回来
把结果物化出来。对数据库来说，这能做到，也不算太糟，但把它放在关键路径上会很慢、很不理想。因为我们是在多个节点之间做协调，还要把数据聚合起来
再返回给客户端。所以这正是 Cursor 大放异彩的地方——大规模重构。你可能得把一个跑了十年的应用从头翻一遍，给每个查询都加上 customer ID，改变每条
调用路径，来避开 scatter gather。你看这里，我们加上了 customer ID。我们知道数据是按这个分片的，于是就能精确落到正确的分片上访问 orders 表，不再需要 scatter gather。我们
只访问一个分片就返回了。但如果你拿的是一个老应用，要做到这一步需要大量重构，还要真正审查所有调用点。这就是 Cursor 现在在这个演示里做的事。那我们可以回到
vitest 工作流。可以看到工作流正在运行。我们加了新的路由规则，正在跑这个流程。它在复制数据，记录自己在做什么，非常安全。现在它开始切换副本
流量了。趁着它在做这些，我们再笼统聊聊基础设施。真正的产品非常复杂，对吧？这个行业一直太痴迷于‘创建的那一刻’。我们确实能很快把东西做出来，
很快就能把沙盒数据库拉起来。但未来不在那里。创建只发生一次，做完就完了。真正重要的是应用的长期演进。
有些应用是跨越几十年建起来的，对吧？我们经常要跟快 20 年的产品打交道。好了，分片完成了。我们回到这里看看，一切正常。我们的应用
开始正常工作了。希望接下来能把订单量拉上去。成了，你看这个订单量的巨大飙升。我们的查询处理速率刚刚大幅提升，因为我们
现在把负载分散到了一个完全分片的集群上。分片完成了。现在我们有了一个分片的 PlanetScale 集群，全搞定了。不过我们做 PlanetScale 比做智能体更早。谢谢。我们当初是为最不稳定的
智能体——也就是人类——而构建的。我们这么做，是因为人类必须操作数据库，所以我们让它在默认情况下就极其安全。后来我们转向为智能体构建，而它们工作起来要快得多
很好的是，我们已经有这些安全防护，让它们可以放手去做。我们真正遵循的是 Unix 哲学：小而锋利的工具。你把工具收窄，就能减少歧义、提高可靠性。
组合能在不增加风险的前提下扩展智能。把小的、可组合的部件和安全机制通过狭窄的接口组合起来，我们就能用一串串简单工具，替代复杂的决策。
让智能体用它们来构建。这些就是其中一些工具。再说一次，这些只是我们构建的示例，但我相信未来每个基础设施平台都得做这些事。你可以把这些用于
各种不同任务。你可以只看推荐，可以为了 CI 做分支。并不是每次用分支都得改 schema。你有在线 schema 变更，也见过回滚的能力，
还有异常检测。这些都来自后端一个庞大的平台。我们必须运行巨大的数据处理流水线和数据仓库，来处理每秒数千万条打在我们平台上的查询。
把它们收进来，随时间分析每条查询的性能，给出建议。基础设施平台将不得不在水面之下构建大量基础设施，来支持与智能体协作，从而规模化这种专业能力。我很喜欢的一个例子是
流量控制。我们刚为 Postgres 做了这个。你可以把资源隔离精确到查询级别、凭证级别、查询标签级别，精细控制集群上任何应用能用多少资源。这
能让智能体在你的数据集里自由操作，而你知道，一旦它们做了任何会影响性能的事，就会被杀掉。做 schema 变更时也一样。当我们正在做
schema 变更时，我们会监控你的查询是否开始变慢。如果出现复制延迟，我们实际上会给系统加上背压，放慢它正在做的事。我们接下来会很快过一遍
刚才在演示里经历的各个阶段，从指令的角度。我们用平台原语来收窄指令，告诉智能体该做什么。我们会经历一个开发流程，先让智能体明确它们
需要做什么，然后它们再走更传统的开发流程：分支、部署、回滚。这些都是原语，必须由智能体自主管理，而且智能体要能监控
自己所做工作的状态。复杂的后端仍然会把这些消息提炼成一个提示。这样一来，就不再需要人类翻网页、看图表、找关联，基础设施
必须把极其精准的信息呈现出来，供智能体行动。好的基础设施会把这种专业能力变成原语。我们在 PlanetScale 是家小公司，但我们拥有数百年的数据库专业经验。我们现在可以把这些经验传递下去，通过
我们把系统构建到人们的智能体上，这样他们就能极其快速地构建。这扩展了一种新的工作方式。我们以前从未能为客户编写代码。
但现在我们可以指导他们的智能体去做正确的事情，而且我们能非常安全地进行这种改变。我们正在减少智能体所需的权力，对吧？如果你只是把它们扔给日志流和大量数据，它们可能会做错事。
把事情搞砸，然后我们就进入开发阶段。这是目前最热门的讨论点，就是开发阶段。所以我不用深入太多，这是行业现在非常擅长的事情，用智能体。
但隔离验证确保数据被正确访问。它们不能直接有生产权限去给你的客户发邮件之类的。然后是部署。部署在新的基础设施平台上需要是一个受控环境，
智能体可以在其中排队，并行工作，如果那是安全的话，平台保障安全。如果需要顺序执行，那就串行。对吧？我们可能在重新分片或故障转移时阻塞Schema更改。
所有这些都需要平台指令。现在，像这样长时间的状态更改需要背压。我们会暂缓、回推负载、减少正在做的事情，比如schema更改，以响应实时流量模式。
这让智能体在运行中更安全。它们需要观察自己的更改并验证所做的事情。监控闭环，对吧？赋予智能体评估影响的能力，或者当异常触发，说明你搞坏了生产，就回滚。
所以系统必须把跨越复杂基础设施系统的每一个更改与发生了什么、谁做的、哪个智能体做了更改联系起来。
这就是我们在产品中有各种可审计点的原因，这样你能快速了解发生了什么，其他智能体可以在涌现系统中观察变化。
每次你改变基础设施，我们背后运行的数千个服务现在都有了新的涌现行为。我们需要理解并追踪这些，生产行为成为下一步指令。
我们刚刚改变的将产生整个技术栈的知识和洞察，去指导下一批苏醒并执行任务的智能体。每个阶段都遵循同样的模式。我们把复杂的事情隐藏在自动化后面，
这样智能体就能调用那些自动化，利用各个部分来完成它们需要的不同任务。我们把专业知识变成了离散的工具。所以智能体的未来不仅仅是更聪明的模型，
那一定会发生。但即使模型不再变得更聪明，作为一个行业，我们还有很多要构建，让智能体能够对真实动态系统进行操作。第一天极其容易。第一天一切大多正常。
真正的是持续修剪、演进、维护和照料这个几乎像活体操作系统的生产环境，智能体未来需要与之协作。所以基础设施，好的基础设施，才是让智能体运作的关键。
好的基础设施让智能体得以运作。这就是我的演讲。非常感谢大家的到来。